you do not need a feeling of
insufficiency in order to motivate
yourself to go and become a better
version of yourself you can do that
simply because you want to become better
simply because your time on this earth
is limited and in that time you want to
make the most of your minutes here and
leave the world in a better place than
you found it that does not mean that you
need to feel terrified and insignificant
and broken and fragile and insufficient
without making progress this progress is
not going to fill the hole that you feel
inside of yourself that hole can only be
filled by you feeling like you are
enough already
hello everybody i'm back
i'm back
i made it i made it back from austin all
the way to the uk
that flight nearly destroyed me because
it was 24 hours basically without any
sleep but i managed to catch up
and woke up to find that we'd hit 250
000 subscribers on youtube which is
good news it's the that was the outcome
goal the one outcome goal that we had
for the channel this year was 250 000
subs before christmas
and we've done it with
three days four days to spare so
still considering it to win as is
tradition thought that i would do a q a
episode
and there were a lot of questions so i'm
very sorry if it didn't get to yours
either i haven't had time or it wasn't
interesting enough so uh yeah let's get
into it george mack what podcast yours
or others have you re-listened to the
most
naval on joe rogan that podcast it's the
best podcast of all time as far as i'm
concerned it's absolutely phenomenal if
you haven't listened to it
go and check it out naval just drops
calm
mind-blowing wisdom
for a couple of hours and then leaves
and then says i'm not going back on for
a long long time because i want to have
new thoughts the guys
like he's just such a force of nature
awesome awesome episode
sam flett any thoughts on how you
approach political arguments these days
just seems pointless debating anything
regarding politics gender race etc as
everyone is convinced they're right
yes humor
is a really really good tool for this
and this is only something i've realized
recently that
if you try and take it too seriously i'm
aware that these can be serious topics
but if you can approach them with a
little bit of humor
people are it allows a let off valve for
all of the people in the conversation it
stops it from getting too serious so
whenever i i don't talk about it that
much it's a culture of war issue
but in
outside of the show i'm not really that
bothered like it's it is a big cost that
you have to pay and i'm not very
interested in the outcomes at least not
personally so use humor like remember
that it's just a game and everybody is
going to die and in three generations no
one will remember your name so taking
anything too seriously seems a little
bit dumb especially stuff which isn't
directly applicable to you like these
are group dynamics that you're talking
about here so
remember that it's all a game
call campbell have you felt compelled to
share your stance on how covid has been
slash is being handled vaccinations and
lockdowns and masks and more it seems
many other podcasters have diverted
their content toward this topic more
than modern wisdom
and are you going to break the spotify
app with five-star ratings now that
spotify podcast ratings have been
launched okay so second question first
yes uh if you haven't checked your
spotify app you can now rate you can
give star ratings like an apple podcast
on spotify so if you haven't done that
already please find modern wisdom and go
and give me five stars that would make
me very very happy and i want to hit 1k
because we've got a thousand
reviews on apple podcasts and i need the
same
on spotify so go do that link will be
somewhere uh have i felt compelled to
share my stance and how coveted hasn't
is being handled so yes what you've seen
is a lot of podcasters have become
what's called audience captured so they
have found that they can get clout and
plays and money through plays by leaning
into either a pro or an anti-vaccine pro
or anti-lockdown message
the whole covet thing to me
is
it would take an awful lot of research
to have a sufficiently
well researched opinion the background
reading that i would need to do in order
for me to get to the level of competence
and understanding around covid that i
would need
is higher than i'm prepared to put in
and there are so many other podcasters
out there that are leaning into this
topic
plus it just seems like
the information is very very difficult
to pass david fuller from rebel wisdom
has done
more reading than pretty much anyone
that i know on the planet and even he
still has questions around this so yeah
i've purposefully
kind of stayed away from that if a guest
wants to talk about it i'm happy to have
a chat but
i
i don't fancy adding more noise into the
tiny tiny amount of signal that's out
there about covid like i not an
epidemiologist i'm not a virologist i
don't understand public public health i
have my own opinions but
this is quite a serious situation so i
think you know letting the experts speak
at least on this one like this is the
one that i cannot give my
cod psychology bro science opinion on
i'll leave leave the experts to this one
terry the tough [ __ ] someone somewhere
sometime did the biggest fart in the
history of humanity question what
country and what era do you think they
were from
guesses on duration
i love
everything about this question including
the name um
what country what person in time would
have had the most well it's got to be
modern day i think more processed foods
in the modern day
i mean
there's some there's some big boys in
america i saw some big boys
while i was traveling um
but then they eat lots and lots of
greens in somewhere like japan and you
could imagine some little japanese
grandmother just
cracking out a big one and it was just a
big fat one out of nowhere
uh
i'm gonna go with the i'm gonna go with
the little japanese lady i'm gonna say
modern day
japan
like one of the just a village in japan
uh guesses on duration well what what
are you looking for here is the biggest
fart how long it went for because she
could have just squeezed a little one
out for a long amount of time or is it a
is it the volume of gas that's left or
is it the size of the noise is it how
loud the the actual fart itself was um
if i was gonna say duration i can't see
how much longer than about a five second
five seconds of actual gas passage
i don't think that you can beat that so
i'll say five seconds
could have heard it easily could have
heard it next door maybe two houses away
uh japanese lady
uh real paul dano do you regret talking
to gadsad after the guru's pod so for
people who
aren't aware of what any of this means
there is a podcast called decoding the
gurus they featured an episode that i
did with gadsad and they had some uh
less than complimentary things to say
about it and then i went on the their
podcast to do a right of reply and kind
of explain my position and stuff and
that that seemed to go down really well
i was really happy with the with the
response to people to my response um
i don't regret speaking to gads at all
no that whole process of being featured
on decoding the gurus and then speaking
to the guys afterwards has been really
really valuable i mean it wasn't very
comfortable it was
like it's not nice to have someone
critique something that you really
really care about
but
some of the things that they brought up
have led me to become a better podcaster
so
i'm all for it the ends justified the
means even if the means were kind of
pretty shitty at least in terms of my
experience
aaron has herpes
what do you feel has been the formula
slash circumstances that significantly
increase your popularity on youtube
man i don't know again [ __ ] what
one absolutely awesome username
i don't know
where we're at with youtube at the
moment it still feels i
i'm a bit biased right but i think that
modern wisdom is
hopelessly undersubscribed and
press subscribe obviously if you haven't
done already but
like
i really really i've always loved the
conversations i've always loved the
guests that we've had on here if i
wasn't running the show i would
subscribe to it and that's why i've made
it um
when i look at some of the stuff out
there that is
crushing it in terms of plays i do
sometimes think like what are we missing
i don't know what it is i know that
we've we're doing well and a quarter of
a million subs is nothing to sniff at
but
maybe it's just the case that we're
playing catch-up uh maybe
the difference i feel like there's a
difference between the quality of the
content the quality of the conversations
and where the channel is at and i feel
like that there's still a lot of
low-hanging fruit for us to pick up but
the biggest difference this year has
been that we got really serious about
clips we did a rebrand so all of the
thumbnails look really nice and
beautiful and they're all consistently
designed so you can kind of got this
signature style you know that it's us
just simple stuff and then you know
continuing to pick up good name guests
but then you know you look at an episode
like vincent haranam or adam lane smith
these guys are essentially nobodies
right internet in terms of internet
cloud they're nobodies you put them on
the internet and have an awesome
conversation with them and it absolutely
bangs so
focusing on clips making sure that we
were consistent with that improving the
quality of the thumbnails just like
little things but personally i'm hoping
that there is a
we feel like we're in a hockey stick
right
i'm really hoping that this just is the
very beginning of the hockey stick and
we've got tons of headroom above also if
you want to help just comment for the
algo in fact you can comment
commenting for the algo just do that
whenever you see an episode just click
on it and comment and then we can
speed up this manipulating of youtube's
algorithm in a completely unethical way
alana marie one why is it so stressful
to try and niche down
good question so i'm guessing that this
is someone who's a creator what she's
referring to is that when you begin a
channel
often
given advice is that you're supposed to
niche down you're supposed to find a
particular microcosm of a broader
subject area and you're supposed to
really really focus on that because it
means that you can find love within a
community very quickly the reason that
it's so stressful to do that is that by
choosing to do one thing very very
tightly you're choosing to say no to all
of the other things that you could be
doing so that causes you to it's just
fomo basically you're looking at all of
the other topics that you might be able
to do and thinking oh well
by by focusing on fitness that means
that all of my insights about
[ __ ] cryptocurrency they they're not
going to work or because i'm going to do
things to do with cooking at home that
means that my dog walking content is
going to go down the path so
you need to give up
one thing
for another thing you it by niching down
you are inevitably saying no to a whole
bunch of other stuff which is why
choosing the niche is really important
but that being said i'm not the best
person to speak to about niches i just
stuck my middle finger up at niches and
decided to speak to you know a porn star
and a philosopher and a psychologist and
whatever back to back to back
um
so personally depending on what the type
of content is i think that you can get
away with rapid growth without niching
down
and if you want to do it you are going
to suffer some stress especially if you
have a wide range of interests because
you're going to see all of the things
that interesting buffet of options that
you are not choosing to
look at
adam dixon95
do you limit your phone use and if so
what strategies do you use
yes i do massive into phone reduction
and tech reduction so sleep with your
phone outside of your bedroom don't use
your phone before a certain time and
don't use it after a certain time so
like intermittent fasting for your phone
all of the apps off your main home
screen remove siri search so you can't
search for it uh and what's the other
one
[Music]
there is another one
that i mean do that do those things and
you will change you will have a hugely
redefined relationship with your phone
oh take social media off your main phone
and get i have a second phone which is
for instagram and twitter and stuff and
that is wi-fi only so when i go out of
the house i can't use social media um
those those will make a huge difference
even just sleeping with outside of your
room and the don't use it before a time
and don't use it after a time that's a
game changer
mindful mitch
would you rather fight a komodo dragon
or a drunk pitbull
do you mean
do you mean pitbull
the rapper drunk
or do you mean a dog which has been
inebriated because
pitbull the rapper kind of looks like
he's drunk all the time
and
i
i don't know i feel like a drunk pit
bull dog would make it easier to fight
and i think a komodo dragon is already
pretty i give me pitbull i want i don't
want
because you've been insufficiently
precise with your language here
i don't want a drunk pit bull the dog
i'll take on
pitbull the rapper
drunk
any day of the week
and i'll feed him to the komodo dragon
once i'm finished
anything that would make your life more
fulfilling right now from jojo mclaugh
um
more impact i think would be is going to
be one of the
things that i push for next year um i
really want to use we've worked hard at
building a platform right and although i
still feel like we're hopelessly under
subscribed that we get to reach you know
a few million people a month and i
really want next year to try and
push
a lot
to do things that optimize for impact
and optimize for making people's lives
better
i did a free
end-of-year review
template process thing which you can get
if you haven't done your end of year
review yet it'll
appear up here chriswilex.com
review you can go and get it for free um
and that was cool people messaged me and
said hey man i just wanted to let you
know i've finished the end of your
review i've got really clear about the
things that i want next year
and it made me feel very very cool so
more stuff like that more
high impact things but life's pretty
fulfilling as it is so yeah if if i can
beat where i'm at at the moment i'll be
pretty impressed
connor
bavidas
what is something that motivates you to
make content i've been watching you for
some time now and it seems very grueling
and intimidating to get interviews and
put out podcasts when you're just
starting how did you cope with that and
work through it
um
there's two two separate questions here
so motivating me to get through the
grueling side and then intimidating when
you first start
intimidating when you first start just
don't take it too seriously know that
you're basically go you're a noob right
you're a white belt at whatever it is
that you're trying to pursue so just
treat it like that okay you're gonna
mess up more times than you're
successful for the first however long
that you do whatever your pursuit is you
know let's use content creation for that
but it's the same with anything you're
going to [ __ ] up
over and over and over and over again
just accept that okay this is just
another lesson that i need to add to the
pile and every single time that you get
one of those it is one time fewer that
you're going to make a mistake in future
so
that would be
that that's exactly how i saw it when i
first started like it's skill
acquisition and this is a skill which is
incredibly complex and lots and lots and
lots of people are very very good at and
if i compare myself to them then i'm
going to feel like
terrible
and then something that motivates me now
i guess to keep going is
it's like a habit man like if i didn't
have
two to three conversations for a couple
of hours per week
i would feel like there was something
wrong i would feel like
i i don't know like i'm thirsty and need
a drink but the drink is a conversation
it's just it
shows the power of routine look at a
really punishing schedule which i still
find difficult and yet when you slowly
build it up over time you go from one a
week to two week to three a week plus
guesting plus editing plus clips on
youtube plus content on youtube plus
newsletter plus everything else
like you just get there step by step and
that's the whole
it takes 10 years to become an overnight
success thing you look at people that
have been doing whatever it is for a
long long long time and you think god
they seem almost superhuman
and
you don't realize that all that they've
done is taken some very very very slow
steps over time consistently
and they get there and to them they're
just like oh this is just what i do like
yeah i'm all right at this but
yeah
slowly slowly that's all you do
uh
m
[Music]
23 loved your openness to chat and learn
with decoding the gurus very refreshing
thank you yes i was the first person uh
actually that asked to go back on to go
and have a chat with them that was
one of the more
um
not stressful but i was excited like i
was really really excited to go and
speak to them uh and and sort of put
myself up against two guys that are
they can be quite disagreeable they're
smart dudes they're quick um and i was
looking forward to having a conversation
and it was it went better than i think
any of us could have hoped and me and
chris cavanaugh the host of decoding the
gurus had already had this big
three-hour chat so i already had a
sensation that it could be really good
and like a really amazing episode and it
ended up being great so i appreciate the
guys for being good sports and letting
me come on
inexorable what belief slash beliefs do
you hold that you suspect your
subscribers would most disagree on or
find surprising
so i've i really got changed by the
conversation i had with andrew gold
when he spoke about spending time with
pedophiles and pedo criminals uh the
difference being that pedophiles are
attracted to children and pedo criminals
act on it but the pedophiles don't they
sort of understand that their sexuality
is something which they can't act on and
um just increasingly the more that i
learn about
that section of the world people who
are born with an attraction to children
and choose not to act on it but are
still
they still feel incredibly alienated
from society and you know unsurprisingly
the belief would be that pedophiles
it seems to me like they need a
they need sympathy um you know we we
need to find a way to make these people
that don't choose
to
act on their impulses
but they
they are working hard to try and control
something which they've just been cursed
with you know they didn't choose their
sexuality you do not get to choose what
you are sexually attracted to
and yet somebody who's working so hard
simply to try and not do something that
they know all of society is going to
hate them for
them finding out that they they're
alienated and you know
lambasted by all of society like it just
it makes me feel
real uncomfortable i don't know what the
solution is either and like
we should be understanding of people who
aren't acting on their impulses but do
find children attractive
is i mean that's not a particularly
popular line of thinking
and you know
people that read tabloids it's quite
easy to like lock them up lock them up
[ __ ] nonces and you go well yeah the
ones that act on it i'm happy to
castrate them but the ones that don't
like they didn't choose to be this way
and this uh it's just my empathy kicking
in that i really struggle
to just imagine that like imagine that
that was the way that you were born that
that was what
life had gifted you as your sexual
proclivity could have been gay could
have been straight
could have swung both ways
no had to get given this
and
yeah that's something
that increasingly i think
will be more and more of a conversation
right we need to integrate people into
society so that'll be one
jake
rock
thoughts on bitcoin
so i think this is supposed to be
thoughts on bitcoin but you've spelled
it as thoughts so i'm going to talk
about thoughts on bitcoin and yes you
are right there are loads and loads of
girls that look like they should be on
only fans that promote crypto and nfts
and what you're seeing there is
basically
decentralized only fans
all that you've got is girls who are fit
with big instagram followings or big
twitter followings talking about nft
drops and stuff and then guys that want
to simp for them are buying these nfts
or investing in this crypto thing hoping
that they're going to get attention
from the girl that talked about it so
that is
my thoughts on thoughts
on bitcoin
sam h smith do you think that the
podcast space develops ideas or does it
simply propagate the ideas that
individuals have on their own
that is a [ __ ] great question
um this has come from the locals by the
way which has some terrifyingly smart
people in modern wisdom locals is like
a radically sensible group of cultists
um
so i definitely think that there's new
things that come out of it because when
two people are putting their ideas
forward and they're focused on the
conversation in front of them they can
end up synthesizing things in a new way
for instance
yeah for instance i had a conversation
with vincent haranam a little while ago
and neither of us said it but both of us
realized that one of the implications of
having a vast class of underclass of
sexless men and women who are struggling
to find a partner which is up and across
their dominance hierarchy one of the
potential solutions probably an
unpopular one would be to have one woman
sorry one man with many women and just
pick the men that are the they've got
the most status of the elon musks of the
world right he can fund the lives of
30 000 women the same as one millionaire
now i'm not proposing that as an idea
however that was something that neither
of us had thought of before that podcast
so i do think that it develops ideas
however
there is a lot of just regurgitation and
i see this in myself right like i'm
having a conversation with somebody
about something they bring up a topic
and i have my answer i i have the line
that i've i
have said in the past
so
good
podcasters try when that comes up to
reassess okay do i just
release the same
sequence of words that i usually do or
should i try and assess whether or not i
have a new insight around this and
that's really really difficult
especially if you're podcasting multiple
times per week because you don't have
a bottomless pit
of things to tap into you know you're
not this
endless well of insights so you are
going to repeat yourself um however
i think that
there are some new things that come out
of the podcast space how many people act
on them and make changes in the world
because of it
it's probably a bit of a different
question uh hawaii escape co
did you know the petersons were going to
recruit you to teach what will you teach
so that isn't my announcement about the
petersons i'm afraid that that's a swing
and a miss
hawaii escape co uh that's not what's
happening next year
butterfly basher just curious can't find
any interviews with women on the scroll
down of your page do you only talk to
men and is that on purpose slash what
you've based your podcast on
uh you haven't looked hard enough
i'm afraid
there are many interviews with women on
there anna lemke this year has been one
of the most played um however
it is
much easier to find men who want to say
yes
the public intellectual space is still
dominated by men if you
look at most of the people that are
writing non-fiction in the areas that i
talk about it is dominated by men so
there is a skew that way
and being honest it is easier to get men
to say yes to come on the podcast i
don't know why
but my strike rate with getting guys on
is easier i definitely don't have i'll
have my biases that i'm unaware of but
there's no i don't think i'm not going
to get that person on because it's a
woman i'm going out of my way to try and
find interesting women to speak to but
you know if you've got suggestions if
you have this is the same thing i always
say whenever someone
pipes up and says there's not enough of
whatever type of person
my first answer my question back is who
would you suggest who do you want from
the subgroup so if you can't find
interviews with women
on the podcast
what women would you like me to speak to
tell me and i'll get their emails and i
will reach out to them if they're
interesting
zero gratification favorite bring me the
horizon
song
[ __ ] great question
uh
probably
sempaternal's got to be the album
um
because that was just
that that entire live show was amazing
the production was phenomenal me and my
buddy mark went to go and see them at
in manchester maybe the men
i think
it was just it was outstanding and then
i was that drown was that uh
whatever the one with the umbrella was i
don't know but that and probably
avalanche favorite song
politically homeless how can you bring
in new people that may not be on the
radar but who have ideas that deserve to
be explored
this is a [ __ ] awesome question as
well so increasingly now as the show
grows and as we do more and more plays
and get more and more reach this is this
[ __ ] fires me up so much finding someone
that is an absolute animal and doesn't
yet have a platform and now i can be
that person who can take this
little unknown rough-hewn diamond and
just give them enough
uh boost boost that signal
and they can go and absolutely smash it
so adam lane smith is a perfect example
of that from this year
he did this awesome twitter thread i saw
it i said if he can podcast one [ __ ]
tenth as well as he can tweet this guy's
gonna be an animal sure enough came on
smashed it second most highly played
episode of the year
which is behind it's jordan peterson and
then adam lane smith nobody
psychotherapist from the middle of [ __ ]
knows bum [ __ ] and that
that gasses me up so much so interesting
so cool that i can now be
a magnifying glass or a megaphone for
people who really deserve it who've got
talent but just haven't managed to find
a platform vincent haranam's the same
thing lauren johnson that um
mental performance coach who worked with
the new york yankees for years exactly
the same
and then adam goes and does
uh michaela peterson's podcast and
launches a course and does a bunch of
other things lauren johnson after she
did me she went and did ben bergeron's
show
vincent harinam john peterson's reached
out to me and said that he wants an
introduction to him after the episode
that i did so it's it's so cool like
that's the best thing and it's
it's weird because i can still remember
the time you know when you begin a
podcast where you're desperately asking
for other people's assistance to grow
your clout and that's you know not to
say that i'm not still doing that but
i can be that person now for
other people and that's like it's so
dope
uh lyndon wonder if you think there is a
small town mentality in the northeast
that keeps a lot of people from
venturing very far both spiritually
mentally and physically
yes
absolutely i mean
this is probably the same anywhere right
small town mentality people that are
born live and die here they find their
partners here they get married here they
have their kids here their kids maybe
even go at the same school that they did
or they're in this similar sort of
catchment area
it's probably the same all over the
world but
it's a part of the northeast that makes
me
like kind of uncomfortable it's like it
the small-mindedness is
is my least favorite part of it and i go
out of my way to find if you look at the
list of friends that i have that are
from the northeast they're people that
you wouldn't think were from there and
that's not to say that there's nothing
that there's something wrong with a
small town mentality
but it's not the sort of life that i
want to live and that means that if i'm
not careful i'll start to adopt a bunch
of values from people that i don't want
to inculcate myself so yeah it
absolutely does and if that's you if
you're around those people then just
find yourself a new community of people
they are out there it's a little bit
more difficult to find in you know spit
and sawdust salt of the earth
working-class towns
what they're there
ryan g ham ryan cam
uh have you ever have you ever had a
guest who was that much of a [ __ ]
that you had to not air the episode so
i've never had someone be a [ __ ] but
maybe one in
50 just don't go
very well
and i'll choose to not air it for a
couple of reasons
firstly
it doesn't show the guest in a good
light like if if i have a conversation
with someone and it's just not that
interesting or they're not in that game
or they're not making sense like it's
not good for them so let's say it's for
through a publisher or it's for their
new book or whatever it's not good for
them to have that content out there and
you guys dedicate
you know an hour or 90 minutes three
times a week to the podcast
and although i could
hopefully ride the waves of a few months
worth of like subpar episodes and you
would still come back and listen to more
and i am conscious of the fact that
there is a high competition for people's
attention online and you're really only
as good as the next thing that you put
in front of your audience and yeah over
time
hopefully the loyalty that's been built
up means that people have confidence in
me even if there's an episode that isn't
quite for them
but i do try and avoid that like it is
one really good way to
cannibalize your own
audience very quickly is to just put out
a bunch of [ __ ] episodes or a bunch of
[ __ ] content um so yeah there's maybe
one in 50 so like what's that two
percent
like a two percent failure rate on
bringing people on uh and the most
annoying thing about it
is not only obviously i've taken up the
guests time but like it's them that was
this [ __ ] guess so it's not my fault
the worst thing about it is that
i've taken up a slot recording with that
person which means that i now need to
record four the following week just so
that i can keep on with the same
publishing schedule and if i'm already
behind or if i've maybe only got one
booked in this week i'm like right okay
so that's a five day week next week for
me to record in order for me to just
stay
on track with how many i need in the
bank
abby swann do you think you'll ever do
any live events like james and diren etc
uh yeah i'd love to seeing james smith
who is a fitness pt guy from the uk for
those of you who don't know uh and
darren cartel who's like his other half
um they both do live events around their
books around their courses or around
just things that they've been talking
about and watching that live is
powerful it's really cool so i would
love to do that i don't know whether
we're at the stage whether that's
realistic um
there's a few
conversations being had behind the
scenes about some cool [ __ ] that we
might do over the next year to 18 months
um and if i was to write a book then
i would almost definitely try and do a
live tour of the back of that just
because it would be awesome to speak
about it
in front of an audience and then get
audience feedback
um yeah it's
it's fun i don't know i don't know that
there's probably going to be any bigger
of a buzz than to talk about something
that you genuinely care about on stage
in front of a group of people who all
know you who all are
built similar to each other who are
familiar with your stuff uh like the the
way that you must feel after you do that
is is amazing
next up
jack
dankels do you consider jacking off to
be a sport
uh
depends how frantically you do it
like
vigorous
vigorous
fapping
would make for a high intensity workout
but it's probably going to be pretty
short
um and also perhaps dangerous
but
do you consider jacking off to be a
sport
i wouldn't like to see
the channel that tries to commercialize
that
you know if we get you know in the these
dystopian futures 500 years in the
future and all of society's just
descended into this limbic hijack grey
hell um
when jacking off becomes a sport
i think
we can just the simulation can just get
turned off like that's that's the final
horseman of the apocalypse when jacking
off is a sport
lj22 you've mentioned before that it is
difficult for content creators who are
learning their craft and building a
following to keep to a path signposted
by the moral compass when there are so
many incentives to plump for audience
capture instead now that you've reached
250k which do you feel has potentially
been dialed down more the devil's on
devil on the shoulder that tells you to
uh tells you that the data on a large
group of people would allow you to grow
the channel at a faster rate by giving
them what they seem to respond to best
or the angel on the shoulder that says
that the larger audience now allows you
to potentially play with a narrative
that could challenge people to listen to
views across the aisle eg david pakman
or to a more rounded set of contributors
eg patrick moore eisenstein richard
betts ultimately do you feel more
compelled to grow by giving the people
what they want or more freedom to
challenge the audience you have built or
neither or both uh this is
a [ __ ] sick question it's another one
that's come from the locals as you can
tell um
[ __ ] this is so good
i would be
i i don't think
that
audience capture
right now is something that i need to be
too worried about
like
i'm my integrity is sufficiently high at
the moment it
might change in future but i'm concerned
about having interesting conversations
with people i'm concerned about trying
to have optimizing for impact next year
you know really really trying to add to
people's lives having making them listen
to conversations that's awesome that
being said
bringing someone on like a david pakman
that challenges views
heavily
for an audience that has become
that has started to expect a particular
style of argumentation
that requires a really the only people
that are really really interested in
that are super super academic or really
really intellectually minded or people
that go out of their way to find that
sort of stuff and it's going to take
time for me to gently introduce that
sort of content that's like look the
whole purpose of this episode that
you're about to listen to
is to kind of make you feel a bit
uncomfortable or to challenge your
current understandings and your current
beliefs so
i would really love it if i get to the
stage where i understand exactly what
works in terms of still continuing to
grow the channel because you know we
want to hit a lot more subs than we've
got
whilst also being able to bring on
people that challenge um everyone's
existing ideas um
that's
the more and more that i get feedback
from the audience from you guys the more
that you comment the well-meaning ones
not the ones that are just like a an
emoji of boobs like where you do the you
do the two brackets and then you do the
nipples with full stops and capital y
like the the really good comments they
help and the messages really really help
because they help to direct me toward
what is what is working and what's not
but
i can't have conversations that don't
land you need to have conversations that
actually grow the channel or else what's
the point if you just stuck it whatever
that's a quarter of a million that's the
most that you're ever going to get
that's that's not good enough for me i'm
leaving too much on the table so
i think over time the challenges of a
creator change as you get bigger there
is a combination of more responsibility
but also more freedom
to be able to speak to different people
um i don't like the idea that there is
i don't like someone thinking that there
is any sort of limitation on who i can
or can't speak to but realistically
there is going to be people out there
you know the charles murrays of this
world who wrote the bell curve bringing
him on comes with a whole
load of baggage even if there's equal
sides contesting whether or not that
baggage is true i'm like oh okay right
so i need to go and research whether or
not this guy is as bad as people say he
is and that's contested and then if i
bring him on i have to have a
conversation where do i bring up his old
stuff that we're not sure if it's true
or not sure if it's bad or not sure if
it's good
it's it's a difficult one and
increasingly it's kind of becoming
politicized even in the creator space we
saw this with the decoding the gurus
thing right but
yeah i think
over the next year hopefully continue to
do what we've done this year i think
we've had a relatively well balanced
conversation there's been people from
the left and the right there's been
people have been pro and against i don't
have to do that for everything i don't
want to bring someone on that's pro one
position and think right here we go
here's a series of conversations about
[ __ ] abortion or whatever because
i've decided to bring one person on
because i thought that they were
interesting
but i also think that having that
impulse just having that reminder it
keeps me not in the straight and narrow
but it keeps me moving in the right
direction
rafford x
as you get high visibility in the
cultural sphere what if any conscious
choices slash perspectives are you
applying to keep yourself grounded true
to yourself i.e meeting and interacting
with jordan peterson tim poole and other
high-profile celebs
um
[ __ ] this a good question as well
what am i doing to keep myself grounded
and true to me well
these people are just normal people that
was the main
thing that i realized
when i met jordan and we sat down for
dinner for you know six hours and
i'm two feet three feet away from him
sat across a table
and he's just a normal bloke he's just
just a normal bloke that happens to be
smart right and can communicate his
ideas in in a good way and um
i got a story right so i'll tell you
this one of my friends interviewed a
very well-known uh atheist a long time
ago no about two years ago
and they were setting up in his house
and the guy before they were going to
start said i haven't eaten yet today
would you mind if i just grabbed myself
something he's like no it's fine it's
fine i'll let the videographer crack on
so this guy goes into his fridge and
pulls out a muller corner which is one
of those yogurts where you have compote
in one side and you sort of snap it and
pour it into the other and this guy has
been top of my friend's list of
interesting people to speak to the like
heroic academic titan person
he's looking at him
watching him
he takes the lid off the top
of the yogurt and looks at it for a
while
and then licks it and at that moment my
friend told me that all
mystic
spell that entire
pervasive
wonder
the magic that had been around this
person just went immediately like if you
lick the lid of a yogurt pot
that's the most that's the most normal
person thing that you can do and that's
everyone so that's what i've referred to
as a yogurt-lid moment which is when you
see someone's someone that you really
respect and admire and realize that
they're just a normal
dude bro or dude girl like they're just
a person right they need to wipe their
ass and
get up in the morning and they
forget things and you know they're just
normal people so
it's not um
it's not been as mad you know
it's meeting the temples of the jordan
petersons or the lex friedmans
um
i know give me six months and i might be
so up my own ass that you can't even i
can't even see you anymore i'm just
living this life this unencumbered
[ __ ] a-list of life but for now i i'm
uh i'm just enjoying being like a normal
guy who gets to meet these people who
are also normal people right
hoech
uh if you could give one advice to your
younger self what would it be
um
probably be less afraid i think i was
very conscious about very fearful about
not being successful for a long time uh
and that means that on route to
achieving success it it always felt
bitter
or
not bitter
it always felt tentative and fragile um
and
i'm going to end up where i'm going to
end up right like the the work that i
put in
is going to get me to the place that
it's going to get me to the fact that
i'm i was fearful
around not getting there didn't change
anything other than make the experience
of getting there more unenjoyable that's
all that happened so
yeah if i could give one piece of advice
it would just be fearless right just
things are going to happen allow them to
come and go
pim
legend
uh can we get an idea of the plans you
have with jordan uh next year can we get
an idea of what the plans you have with
jordan next year are about
um
no not yet i'll tell you i'll tell you
in the new year i'm gonna we're hanging
off on announcing until the new year but
you will
you will see it when we do it and it's
gonna be
pretty cool it's going to be very very
cool
birdie 152 does having slash growing
audience does having a growing audience
potential mate pool make it difficult to
find a meaningful relationship um
not really
it's podcasting
you know
like i have a very meaningful
relationship at the moment and
podcasting doesn't influence that i'm
not
if you're logan paul right
and you're constantly flying all over
the world and in nightclubs in miami and
your brother's knocking out tyron
woodley and stuff
that's a little bit different to being
someone
that
researches the dopaminergic balance
system to have a conversation with some
researcher from stanford um
i imagine
that there must come a tipping point
when
your platform is so big that you you
kind of are your body of work like so
think about whatever jordan peterson or
brett weinstein or whoever
like a big
big content creator
they almost they almost don't become
human anymore we almost look at these
people as if they're not human we look
at them as if they're just their work
their body of work and you forget this
is the thing about
the previous question to do with what's
it like meeting these people and how do
you keep your feet on the ground that
from the outside looking in these people
are so much their bodies of work that
they're barely even human anymore
but
i don't know when that i don't know when
that point arrives when people no longer
see you for just being a person i
imagine it must come
i don't know we'll find out we'll find
out you will know because i'll start
wearing a huge
pimp fur coat
cane
top hat and you will have to call me
milady
uh meek cajdee dalton
how do you decide i've been i'm sorry to
everyone i've butchered
every single [ __ ] name today so
apologies
have simpler names have whatever it was
harry has herpes and
terry the terry the dominator or
whatever it was called how do you decide
which speakers you would like to feature
on modern wisdom good question um with
difficulty actually
i am
constantly looking at
books that have been released always
looking at other people's shows i have a
little community with me and michaela
and aubrey and his team and a couple of
other people who kind of
were able to share ideas in a way but
it's not very easy
um and
if you have somebody that you think that
i should bring on just tweet it at me
tweet it at me or send it to the contact
form on the website because if you see
someone that you think is
an awesome podcast guest
i'm why haven't i got them like if you
listen to the show be a part of the show
like you can say
you can curate what it is that you
listen to this is like a [ __ ] choose
your own adventure for netflix thing if
you want something doing tell me if i
can get the person on and if they're
good i'll do it just make sure that you
link something they've already done and
who they are and why i should get them
on make the message short
and just email it to chriswilex.com
contact there's a form on there and just
send it to me and if we can get them on
we'll get them on
uh ratio of podcasts you source slash
guests who request to come on plus
sourcing challenges so as i just said
above
it's difficult because i need to do
three a week that's a very very large
amount of content the problem is i can't
afford to really dilute down the quality
because i'm competing every single
podcast can get taken apart and this is
the problem with the decoding the gurus
thing
each podcast needs to stand on its own i
don't get
more
leeway
because i'm doing three a week and
somebody else does one a month
their quality can be put up against mine
you could put those two episodes side by
side and if mine doesn't match up with
theirs then that's it you just look like
less of a good podcaster so it's hard uh
mostly
and the ratio of ones who request to
come on there are quite a lot of
requests um
the ones that i like the least of the
ones that come in for i'm trying to be
diplomatic here the ones i like the
least are the ones that come in from
agencies it's like
podcastbookers.org and stuff and all
that they do is they just have people
that want to get booked on shows and
just spam them around a list of
podcasters that's kind of
that's a bit shitty uh sometimes you
find diamonds in the roof who want to
come on but the best ones
are ones who other people that you
respect either other podcasters or
well-meaning audience members send and
like
i can't remember who it was
some it's happened at least at least
four of the episodes from 2021
were someone tagging me on twitter and
saying chris you really should get this
person on i watch
you know a little bit of a podcast that
they've linked me with and then i reply
to the tweet and say how do you feel
about coming on name like my dms are
open just let me know and it happens so
if you want to do that
you can all be everybody can be a
researcher right everyone can be
researching for modern wisdom just
[ __ ] make sure they're good
what's your favorite britney spears song
from james jaimin p what's your favorite
britney spears song do you believe
intelligent forms of life exist out in
the universe i'm not sure if these two
are linked
what's your favorite britney spears song
and do you believe in intelligent forms
of life um
i don't have a favorite britney spears
song
sorry
uh what ever happened to her
oh she's in court isn't she
she's in court trying to what's she
trying she's trying to like get her own
net she's the license to be able to take
herself to the toilet or something like
her dad's her dad owns her entire life
and she can't put a pair of slippers on
without his request first or something
that's a weird one um
do i believe in intelligent forms of
life
pass don't usually do this but pass i
really really don't know um
the odds seem so astronomical and yet
selection bias
the uh selection observer effect i think
it's called
where because we are the place that
we've observed it we presume that it has
to be everywhere
but we don't know how unlikely it could
be
one in a trillion trillion trillion
trillion trillion chance uh and we're
the one
and we would be here if that's so we
would be exactly here thinking well
there's got to be some elsewhere
i don't know man don't know
you've started a business and are
allowed five guests from the pod to work
with from has bowls that
is a sick question
um george mack has to be in there i need
i need that man on board john peterson
i'm gonna
uh utilize his ridiculously huge reach
and youtube channel and his massive
email list james smith he's gonna be in
there for comedic relief and because he
understands how to make businesses
who are the other two neither one uh
anna lemke from stamford she can be the
researcher to make sure that we're not
frying our dopamine and she can keep us
sweet
uh and
i was gonna say sienna day the porn star
but that's
that seems like a that makes it into a
different sort of business um
who else would i put in it's the final
one
maybe
maybe ben bergeron and ben can be
cool and he could be like
he could be the performance well
actually who's no so george you'll make
it george will make it happen
i'll be there because for some reason i
i'm allowed in as a part of this james
smith understands the internet thing
john peterson's got the got the platform
and it's going to make sure we don't fly
our fried opening ben bergeron he's team
leader and he coordinates everyone and
makes sure that we're motivated yes
ftse100
um
a schmidt
have you hopes or plans to marry and
raise a family chris i hope so he seemed
like a pretty decent human being who'd
make a good husband and dad
uh well looks can be deceptive can't
they because actually i just intend on i
just want to have children so that i can
use them as pinatas um
yeah that's it i'm just going to hit
them and i hit them with a big stick
but no i'm looking forward to being a
dad i can't wait to be a good husband
and a good dad that would be
it's weird i i think about this more
than i probably should do that
it's going to be one of the most
emotionally intense experiences that i
ever go to
and um
i'm a pretty pretty emotional guy at
times like i feel things strongly in a
nice way
but
having kids is something i don't know
whether i'm prepared for but then
everyone thinks this everybody thinks
that they're
a pro that they're not ready to have
kids and then it happens and apparently
everyone seems to be fine so
what happens when you get so caught up
in watching learning all this great
stuff
that it just becomes your newest form of
procrastination all this new knowledge
still very little action
again an awesome insight that probably a
lot of people struggle with so
the issue that you have is that
you give yourself the feeling that
you're making progress by learning
things through a podcast or by reading
them or by doing whatever it's the
simulacrum of making progress towards a
meaningful long-term goal whilst not
actually doing any of it
and [ __ ] if that if that's not you know
the problem of the self-help world then
i don't know what is
to get around it you just need to lean
into action as much as you can so you
need to become an executor not a
strategist right
one of the stats is that strategy and
strategist
uh in the top 10 words used on all
linkedin profiles and executor or
execution aren't even in the top 100 why
because it is significantly easier to
strategize than to execute so first off
don't beat yourself up about this like
this isn't just a byproduct of the
self-help world this is a fundamental
feature of being a human right it is
easier to theorize than it is to do the
practical work so most people theorize
most of the time one of the things that
i would do is restrict what you're
focusing on so just look at one thing
okay
this month this
week this year i'm going to focus on
this particular thing this one thing so
i want to really i really want to get in
shape like that's my thing and then
forget about the other stuff like
you can enjoy learning about the
self-help as long as you continue to
make progress towards the goal that
you've already identified so i think
planning in advance and understanding
what you're going to suck at
um choosing okay if i want to get in
good shape in the gym then maybe my work
or my
social situation maybe they're going to
take a hit right maybe i'm going to
struggle to go out as much and have as
much fun because i'm going to be working
on my fitness
if that's the case
cool that's the price that you need to
pay in order to do it but you need to
remain focused on the thing what is the
one thing that you want to do make a
plan and then when something occurs
later down the line like you realize oh
[ __ ] i haven't seen my friends in a
while or maybe work's dropping off it's
got okay this was this this is why
you're here
you made the plan for this to happen
you said that you wanted to get in shape
is that goal still true yes it is fine
forget the fact that that's happening
you can get back to doing that in future
leaning into action and trying to find
what is the next physical step that
moves me towards my meaningful long-term
goals
that's the that's the superpower right
the best productivity strategy
of 2022 is to get really really clear
about what you want and then ruthlessly
cull all of the other things that don't
contribute to it and this thing that you
really really want can be to be an
awesome father or to get into a
relationship this isn't me advocating
for
ridiculous productivity at the expense
of everything else i'm not saying that
this has to be in a commercial or
self-growth
paradigm right it can be
you what what do you want
genuinely what is it that you want
pick that thing and then get really
really serious about doing that and
ruthlessly cull everything else you've
already decided in advance what it is
that you want
get rid of the other stuff and just
focus on that
focus on action what is the next little
thing that i can move myself toward
you listen to all of these podcasts it
sounds great pick the thing pick the
thing in advance and just focus on that
s a if you were transported back three
years what areas would you focus on more
and what less
honestly
i'm really really happy with the
development that i've made over the last
five years like that's one of the
reasons why
doing the show feels so good because i
know i know how much headroom there was
for me to grow above where i was like i
was such i mean you know in five years
i'm going to look back on me now and
think what you talking about you total
piss-head
but
looking back i think
i i didn't know anything asked from
elbow and all of the steps that i took
in order to get me i'm sure it could
have been better organized right if ali
abdullah had done it
he'd have had a [ __ ] notion
spreadsheet
tattooed on the inside of his arm it
would have been so much slicker than i'd
done and it would have been procedural
and
overloaded with space repetition and
[ __ ] if yusef had done it he'd done the
same thing but i didn't right but it
worked out okay and that's
i think that's a
to fly the flag for the people that are
totally unorganized i think that's a
much more realistic situation to be in
that you're just going to you're going
to have it like a vague
direction that you think that you're
supposed to go in and no real idea about
how you're going to do it
and then you just keep on trying things
and find some strategies that work like
have a good routine every single day
read expose yourselves to people that
you really think are interesting and
that bring value to you
optimize for action etc cetera and then
you end up realizing okay i've made some
[ __ ] progress here this is pretty
cool
that
it's gone pretty good it's gone pretty
good
uh sd low sa weird are you growing a
full select because i think you should
this is because
uh i just wanted to post a photo that
would get
some comments on youtube so i just put
up a photo a selfie that i took last
year and it was i realized this after i
posted it it was as i was beginning to
grow my mustache
the problem with tom selleck is my mum's
only ever told me
about one
famous man that she fancies and it was
tom selleck so
i don't think
i don't think that my inner awkward
would allow me
to grow facial hair that i know
specifically that my mother's attracted
to
i don't think that that's
an option uh isaac
orellana
how do you keep pushing when your body
says no
good question uh i think the best mantra
that i've got is this is why you're here
so
when you have some fatigue in you when
you're struggling whether this be in a
workout late at night when you're
supposed to be doing work for your
business or
for school or college or uni or whatever
it is that you're doing
this is why you're here you go into the
gym to struggle right you don't go into
the gym to do the warm-up you go into
the gym to do the hard things not the
easy things
so when thing whenever it gets difficult
that's a signal of growth right you're
in the business you're running the
business because you want it to be
successful the way that you make your
business successful is by doing the
things that other companies are not
doing that means that when it starts to
get difficult that discomfort would be
felt by competitor number one and two
and three and four and five
that's why you're here you're here to
step through that degree of discomfort
and you lean into it
uh ben bergeron says that you lean into
discomfort as if you invited it through
the door right
when it happens when you're in a workout
and your lungs start tearing and
everything your vision starts blurring
and starts going in
just remind yourself okay good
this is a sign that i'm doing the thing
that i'm supposed to be doing this is a
signal that i'm moving in the right
direction this is why you're here
uh
do you think
phil lam do you think the person you are
now would get on love island uh i don't
know
i i feel like probably probably well
they don't have people over 32 i don't
think and i'm 33 so
um but
i think probably more likely to get on
than previously uh just because
[ __ ] like that was the difference that
you get when you've spent a little bit
of time on camera is is pretty profound
uh how i would get on on love island
might be a little bit more difficult
because i'm a lot less able to hold my
tongue when people annoy me or when
there's things to say and i would be
much sooner to want to try and trigger
stuff
uh
but
yeah i don't know um
maybe
maybe i would
deborah marinelli how do we manage the
balance between self-love
and
get to the best version of what we could
be feels like a contradiction isn't it
um
balancing self-love and i guess ambition
or growth is a conversation that
i've had so many times this year right
benjamin hardy's new book gap in the
game is all about that you should go and
check that out 260 pages it's brand new
it's really really smart
um however
the implication there is that you can't
love yourself whilst being ambitious
right or whilst trying to be the best
version of you
you do not need a feeling of
insufficiency
in order to motivate yourself to go and
become a better version of yourself you
can do that simply because you want to
become better simply because your time
on this earth is limited and in that
time you want to make the most of your
minutes here and leave the world in a
better place than you found it
that does not mean that you need to feel
terrified and
insignificant
and and broken and fragile and
insufficient without making progress
this progress is not going to fill the
hole that you feel inside of yourself
that hole can only be filled by you
feeling like you are enough already
will that kill a little bit of your
drive i think it will i think that some
of the most ambitious best
uh progressing people on the planet i
think that they are
on average
less happy
than most normal people and they are
compelled by fear of failure fear of
insufficiency to go and do a thing
but do you want that like do you want
to live
a
more miserable life
simply because it provides you with more
success
because if the goal of reaching the
success
is that you'll finally be able to make
yourself happy but on route to reaching
the success you make yourself miserable
you've kind of shortcutted the entire
situation that why not just be happy why
not just give yourself the opportunity
to feel like you're enough and
i understand that we're not totally
rational creatures right and also we
don't we can't just go into our own code
and reprogram it to be like okay you
don't need to play keeping up with the
joneses now you don't need to do the
comparison game or you don't need to
feel concerned that you haven't got the
status or the wealth or the education or
the whatever it is the new car that
however you can consciously design your
life you can step into your own
programming and shortcut it and this is
if there was one core message that i
think i've learned from modern wisdom
over the last four years it's been you
do not live you do not need to live your
life
by default you can live it by design and
that's the goal
you should be living your life by design
not by default your [ __ ] factory
setting programming defaults
are horseshit they are
so bad they do not serve you they do not
make you happy they do not make you
fulfilled you've
imbibed what [ __ ] culture and your
parents and your older brother and the
idiot people that you went to school
with you've consumed and absorbed all of
the stuff that they gave you
and now most of the work that you need
to do is de-programming that and getting
to a place of you what is it that you
want and you can want to be a better
person you can want to be a better
person whilst feeling enough at the
moment and maybe you're not going to be
quite as successful maybe the fear of
insufficiency would propel you an extra
5 or 10 or maybe it's [ __ ] 50
but
if your goal is to be happy and you
think that go becoming successful is
going to contribute to your satisfaction
and your happiness in life
you can just choose to be happy right
now
and in that case it doesn't matter what
level of success you get to
find a thing that you love to do and
you'll never work a day in your life
like find a life that you love to lead
and you'll never need to feel
insufficient
uh big red baptista
uh is it fair to say that you're being
guided by the judgments and limitations
put on you by others decoding the gurus
do you think joe rogan gives a [ __ ] he
had molly you on very much doubt that so
i don't think that i'm being guided
by the judgments and limitations put on
me by others
i don't think that judgment or
limitation
has caused me to act in a particular way
but i do think that or maybe you're
right maybe to give you a jew maybe i am
being guided by that
do you think joe rogan gives a [ __ ] he
had molly new one well he did go back
and redo the jack dorsey episode and
then
had to bring tim pull on to do the
episode with him
so
i i do think that he cares i do think
that joe assesses his own performance in
the same way that i do the decoding the
gurus episode the conversation that i
had with them was insightful because it
was the first time that someone who is
understanding in this space had said a
bunch of things
and part of them resonated as being true
look i need to i needed to learn to be
more skeptical around the guests i have
on on the show and i need to push back
cool okay that's a skill that i need to
acquire
rogan
had a conversation with jack dorsey that
went so badly that his audience tore him
apart and then he he brought him back on
and didn't have faith that he was able
to do what he needed to do himself so
brought somebody else back on so
i don't think that you can say that he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about the
conversations that he's had or about the
people that he's had on or else he
wouldn't have reneged on uh he wouldn't
have gone back and done it again um
also
a lot of people come into podcasting
from another
industry right rogan comedian
commentator
presenter um
however
i've come into this as a podcaster like
my first position in this industry is
i'm podcaster first like a crossfitter
that hasn't come into it from
weightlifting or athletics or track and
field or something i've come into it
from crossfit i've come into it from the
sport that i'm actually trying to do
which means that i'm going to make more
failures and i'm going to have to learn
out loud more
as the show progresses because i didn't
pick up that time when i was doing
a thousand gigs on the comedy circuit
over the space of 10 years or something
right like i didn't get that the
difference is that when you do a
thousand gigs on the comedy circuit like
rogan's probably done in order to build
his skill set up which he can now deploy
on his podcast he does that
that wasn't
immortalized on the internet for
everybody to see and also you don't just
you don't create an audience immediately
like that you know a quarter of a
million people and like whatever it is
two million three million plays a month
that we do all of those people get to
critique my performance um
i'm guided by trying to be the best
person that i can be
having conversations and i will take the
input and the suggestions from anybody
that i think has something correct to
say
um
i'm not blind to the fact that there is
head room for me to improve at doing
this and if i really really want to be
good at this then why would i not take
the suggestion of somebody
a criticism that has value in it is a
gift
like if it's true
the criticism even if it's deployed in a
nasty sideway and i brought that up with
the guys and i was like look like
the truth that you had was um
how would you say not ruined but it was
tarnished by the snidey topspin that
somebody put on it
whether or not you don't like the idea
that a podcaster isn't um
whether or not you don't like the idea
that a podcaster is taking on board the
criticisms of others
doesn't really matter to me i'm adamant
i'm a better podcaster because i do that
because when somebody brings something
up to me david fuller from rebel wisdom
he had some comments to say to me this
year you know [ __ ] if malice rang me
and said hey man you know what it is
here's something that i think and if i
was like oh [ __ ] do you know what it is
that's really really true here's a way
that i reckon that you could really like
up your game with the way that you begin
or end or questions or comments or
whatever storytelling anything i worked
with the speech coach this year i worked
with the diction coach for my tedx talk
and i decided to stick about and keep
him on so that i could work with him for
the podcast i worked with a comedy coach
this year and i'm going to continue to
work with him
like
i'm being guided by the judgment and
suggestions put onto me by others ie my
coaches the fact that the guys from
decoding the gurus or any other podcast
david fuller from rebel wisdom or anyone
that wants to
contribute
the fact that they're not paid for me as
a coach is like that just means i'm
getting more profit out of it as far as
i can see
um
if all that i did was
fold at the first sign of a little bit
of criticism then yeah i think that
there would be
a sign that your
your faith in your own performance isn't
there but when someone's got something
that i think is valid to say then sweet
i'll take it on
karthik
chittara
hi chris can you can you rustle brand on
your channel uh i can well i can't
rustle brand on my channel because i
don't think that i can grow that hair
but i can try and get him on my channel
and i'm speaking to jordan peterson
and michaela at the moment to see if we
can get something linked in maybe even
just to connect with him for now um i
think is there another question about
i feel like there was another question
about russell brand about something to
do with
oh it's down here you've got another
question about russell brown coming um
can i russell brand i will try and
russell brand as best i can but i will
also try and get one
yo van
bedenovich max verstappen or lewis
hamilton i haven't seen it yet
i haven't seen the final race so i'm
going to hold off one thing that i did
see that i thought was quite
noble was
louis was pretty gracious in defeat
wished max well said that he was
sort of happy for this guy um who had
won in quite contentious uh situation in
the formula one um so i'm gonna hold off
jovan but i will i will have a decision
soon
uh pat steadman's polish passport see
these are the these are the sort of
[ __ ] names i'm here for pat stedman's
polish passport that's the [ __ ] i'm here
for
please facilitate a discussion slash
debate moderated by you between rob
henderson and roller tomassie about the
mating market evo psych and what the
stats mean rollo thinks that rob is
generally on the money and knows the
uncomfortable parts about what the data
suggests but he plays it safe or pc when
he's a guest on the more trad con
channels like jordan peterson's
rolo's an interesting one man
rolo
i don't know
rolo is i my mind is still not made up
around whether or not
rollo
gets
his
direction
and his insights which you know he's
contributed to the
meninism red pill space you know pretty
much created it um
there is a degree of
kind of like nastiness to some of the
things that he puts out
that
makes me
wonder it makes me more concerned or
more skeptical around whether or not the
other ideas have
whether they're free of bias right like
there just seems to be and and this
happens this isn't just roller but it
seems to be in a lot of the meninism red
pill space
that the guys
they really take glee
in [ __ ] on women
like they really [ __ ] enjoy
the fact that girls don't understand how
hypergamy works or that girls are going
to hit the wall at 30 or 35 or 40 and
they're no longer going to be interested
no guys going to be interested in them
like that
that amount of glee to me that's the
side of this evolutionary psychology
discussion that i really really don't
like i'm just not bothered about i'm not
bothered about coming on and making
girls feel like [ __ ] i'm
more than happy to push uncomfortable
truths
uh all day long like harsh insights yeah
all day because that is someone having
to deal with
reality coming and hitting them in the
face but there's a limit to that there's
a limit to how
like
mean and nasty that can come across this
was the problem i had with decoding the
gurus so the problem that i had with
them i was like look guys you can have
all of the correct insights in the world
but if you're a dick
when you say it
it's going to dampen the impact and why
are you doing it like what is it that
you're getting out of that that being
said
rob is a [ __ ] awesome dude and he's a
good mate of mine and rollo is an
important figure in this field i don't
think that there would be i mean
plays it safe or pc like rob understands
about the data but plays it safe like
rob's a social sciences researcher and a
phd candidate
at cambridge
like
who's to say that he doesn't actually
just agree
with the
w with not leaning into
[ __ ] on women like he doesn't not
say things he says the things that he
need that are the truth but he doesn't
lean into it in that red pilly way so
i don't know man the
i had a lot of comments saying that i
need to get rolo on the show but i don't
really know what i'm going to talk to
him about i don't want to have a
conversation that makes 50 of the
audience feel like [ __ ]
uh and
that's not the type of
evolutionary psychology that i'm into
like if you look at
[ __ ] jeffrey miller right jeffrey
miller is jeffrey miller's roller
tomassie with academic chops
and
he doesn't
he doesn't lean into things in that same
way
i don't know i
we'll see we'll see what happens over
the next year
sergeant
slimer
if you hadn't had your epiphany in the
love island villa do you think you would
have had it later on in life or not at
all um yeah i think it was coming i
think that
there was a lot of
i don't know just discordance in my life
and i was thinking [ __ ] like is this
really the best that i've got to offer
the world like getting people drunk and
then
[ __ ] going on reality tv in a small
pair of swim shorts
and
that would have happened one way or
another but the fact that it happened in
a really condensed down version really
really quickly was
useful not many people go on reality tv
to be like catapulted toward a night a
life of integrity and virtue but
i'll take it as a win
uh kyle
lalock blaylock uh when will you and
malice travel abroad as soon as we're
[ __ ] allowed like
that's been so frustrating two years
we've been waiting to go to go away we
spoke about this a ton
while i was in
austin
we will see
right we'll see as soon as we can do it
we want to go we spoke about the plans
videographers ready to go we just need
to
get the borders open hail wood
why not pursue an agenda of not only
focusing on individual improvement but
also on structural functionalism a bit
more like russell brand
yeah okay so
i avoid trying to make comments too much
about what i think needs to be done by
society at large
uh structural functionalism
because who the [ __ ] am i to know like
i've only just about started to
understand how i work
and then maybe beginning to glimpse how
other people work
[ __ ] multiply that by
65 million people that live in the uk or
something
i
i don't know the
russell's stuff russell's blown up this
year especially obviously he's leaned
into a lot of the covid's discussion and
i'm looking forward to meeting him and
having a conversation with him
i feel like you know if you take the
jordan peterson approach of clean up
your room and then the kitchen and then
the other things in your house and then
step out into the world fix you before
you try and fix everyone else
that to me feels like the best way to go
along this journey right that by making
myself and the people immediately that i
can
um
influence
as good as we can be individually
then moving that out to broader
uh trends when i get older and when i've
got more insight i just don't feel ready
i don't feel like i know enough to be
able to talk about i'm feeling like i
know enough to have most of the
conversations that i have but to be able
to try and claim structural changes of
how i think things should be moved
totally totally not there and
honestly in situations like this more
noise and less signal isn't what the
world needs
justified defiance how long do twinkies
last i mean if i find a one one thousand
year old twinkie still in the wrapper is
it safe to eat it uh i don't know let's
let's google
how long
to
twinkies last
according to twinkie deconstructed the
snack food only has a shelf life of 26
days any longer than that the sponge
cake turns hard as a rock
hard as a rock which seems pretty measly
compared to the myth
however it's considered quite good
compared to other baked goods
uh
it's a myth
it seems
24 days 25 days
26 days 26 days the longest i found 26
days
uh justified to find so that's how long
uh what does your step-by-step morning
routine look like at the moment this is
from dan bell 99 but there was tons of
questions about this i'm going to
release a morning routine course very
soon and that will just take you through
it it'll be
probably three hours at most from start
to finish it'll explain the principles
of how to put together a good morning
routine how you can stick to it all of
the uh contingency routines that you
need and you'll
end up
making it as well you'll end up
constructing your own one by the time
that you finished hopefully in less than
three hours all in one go uh and that'll
be ready as soon as i get my assing gear
and you will find out on there
uh last one johnny jenning i'm 24 years
old and feel lost in my current career
where were you at 24 and what would you
do
24 i was just out of uni so i just
finished my masters uh in international
marketing at 23
and i was running club nights i was
working
every
saturday all day setting up a club and
then all night running the event and
then during the week
managing [ __ ] myself
making sure that every single one this
was like peak peak
hardcore work mode me and darren were
just nailing it we didn't have any
managers it was just me and him that was
all that we did
like 120 130 staff all managed by us no
people underneath us and um
it took up a lot of time uh what would i
do if i was 24 years old and feel lost
in your career
man
not fear like you're going to be
absolutely fine you're 24 you have an
endless and this is such a this is like
exactly the same [ __ ] that my mum would
say to me but you have so much time to
find out what it is that you want to do
if you feel lost in your current career
then leave leave go abroad for a chunk
of time and work in a bar
go do a season abroad somewhere and go
work in a bar work as a pr for a a club
or work as a [ __ ] assistant in a
museum or whatever it is that you want
to do right you will find things that
you gravitate toward
more easily you do not need to focus if
if you're lost and you don't know what
to do it sounds like you're struggling
to find out even a direction out of the
career that you don't like
just do a bit of traveling spend some
time with a patent interrupting to your
current routine new places new people
new food new smells new experiences all
that [ __ ] and you will not be able to
hold on to your old modes of thinking
there's going to be so much new stimuli
coming in that all you can do is notice
the things that arise that you find to
be interesting and notice the things
that arise that you don't like over time
those patterns will start to repeat
and that is what life is
life is you noticing patterns of things
that you like to do and don't like to do
and leaning into the ones that you like
you're split testing the experiences of
your life and over time you get closer
and closer and closer to the ones that
you want to do and
hopefully you find them you know there
are
an unlimited number of things that you
can spend your time doing so sticking to
something that you know that you feel
lost in when you've got so much freedom
and so much spare time you don't need to
do it man
be good
that's it [ __ ] that was a lot of
questions dear lord and that was cut
down as well that was cut down by about
half so uh thank you to everyone who
submitted a question and thank you to
everyone who follows the channel like a
quarter of a million sub for all that i
can [ __ ] and moan about the fact that
we haven't got enough subscribers right
uh a quarter of a million subs is is
mental so thank you
to everyone who has subscribed
press comment for the algo every time
that you see a video that's the one
thing if you want to thank me right for
hitting 250k can do two things
first thing go on to spotify and give
this show five stars that would make me
very happy second thing just comment for
the algo whenever this you see the stuff
come up that that's it
that's all i got all right
peace
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace